hi guys in this video I want to talk
about why I love almond flour so much
first of all it's gluten-free you can
make cookies muffins bread keto bomb
all these things with it and as a
glycemic index of less than one wheat
flour is like a glycemic index of 71
it's off the charts but check this out
if we compare almond flour to wheat
flour protein it has 22 grams versus 10
grams for wheat carbs 19 vs. 76 grams so
it's like you're eating sugar fat at
high in fat 56 grams versus 8 grams so
we want that fat 5 or 10 + 2 grams
potassium 687 grams of potassium here
you are consuming all these vegetables
but you probably didn't realize this
almond flour will give you some
potassium to look at wheat has 149
milligrams then we have magnesium 279
milligrams wheat only has 25 calcium 216
wheat has 20 vitamin E 26 wheat has 0.8
if it's whole wheat and point 1 if it's
white bread okay so it's basically no
vitamin E so I highly recommend use
almond flour in some of your recipes put
your comments below hey if you haven't
already subscribed press this little
button down below okay thanks